for no timeouts as you see no timeouts
for the Cavs
time to catch and shoot but that's it
but first Grant's got to make one of
these
[Applause]
every night in the NBA man I'm telling
you
what a story Grant Williams Ken Wright
now he has to hit it I was gonna say if
you miss
the first one if you make the first I
would miss the second
now Joe Missoula is going to get Luke
Cornett and Blake Griffin in here
because if Grant misses the second the
Celtics have nearly 10 offensive
rebounds in this fourth quarter the
Celtics if there's a grant Williams Miss
here could get a shot to tap it in watch
out for over the back there's a lot of
things going on here the green One's
Gonna Make this shot
83 on the year but this is not a regular
free throw
[Applause]
stuff going on out here
doesn't go and neither does the tap
the Celtics get free throws in the final
second and still these two teams find
their way to overtime